first of all i am loving your new song
bad habits for some reason i thought i
was gonna hear a lullaby from you or a
soft ballad this is an
awesome song thank you um well all of
that is on the album i just i feel like
when i start
an album campaign if i come with what
people expect it
it's quite boring for me and it's quite
boring for them it's just a kind of box
tick and everyone goes oh it's the
ballad whereas i think
when i came with shape of you on divide
everyone was interested suddenly because
it was something different
yeah well it definitely has me hooked
can't wait to hear the rest of the music
when you think about bad habits what
would you say are some of the bad habits
that you've kicked over the past few
years that you feel has really changed
your life
uh i just everything was
excess for me it was always like there
was no off switch like i would just
i loved junk food i loved boozing i
loved like
or even exercise i did to excess i would
like instead of like
exercising properly i would just run on
a treadmill for an hour and i think
that you know i just i think i've i've
learned
to uh have moderation is key
like everything is all right even bad
habits are fine if they're done in
moderation
but i would do my bad habits in excess
basically
yeah so what would you say kind of
changed your mind about you know doing
things in excess is it turning 30
is it just kind of this point in your
life no it's definitely having a kids
definitely have a good kid i think as
soon as you have
a child selfishness goes out the window
and you have to
exist as a parent and i mean also i am
myself and i do my own thing but like
i'm not making decisions
based on what i want i'm not saying i'm
going to go out till 5 a.m in the
morning because i want to i'm going to
be like
oh i have to be up in two hours to look
after my daughter that's that's my
priority tonight
yeah well basically one of the the
lyrics to in this song is nothing
good happens after 2 a.m so how does 2
am look different
now than it did maybe five years ago 2am
has always looked the same let's not
let's not get it twisted no one no one
thinks that
anything after two is good but five
years ago i would have still chased it
and being like no no
you're wrong tonight we'll get the vibe
back we'll get but it's mate it's always
it's here here in england i don't know
what it's like in
in canada but here in england it just
goes to two subjects it's either
brexit or donald trump and the night
after two it just ended up
everyone sits around the table and it
just turns to that conversation before
you know it at six o'clock in the
morning
and nothing's happened nothing's good
has happened you just you've just talked
about stuff that you've watched on the
news
that week and it just goes round and
round and round but yeah
i feel like i feel like that's the topic
of conversation all over europe for the
last like
six years yeah it feels like it's just
this continuous loop you're absolutely
right
um do you find that even your style of
music has changed since becoming a dad
no because i don't actually think i have
a style of music i think i write songs
and whatever style they are they are but
i've never liked
i've never thought of myself as a genre
i don't actually believe in
genres i think there's well i think
there's two genres there's good
music and bad music and you either fit
in one of them with what whatever song
you
you come out with but i don't think it's
changed my style of music but it's
certainly changed the way i feel like i
like feel in inside i feel like being a
dad that opens up a portal of love that
you didn't know existed but
equal to that love you've got an insane
amount of worry so you've got more love
and more worry
yeah it's a lot a lot of emotions
um you know you've talked in the past
about bouncing off music
off artists like taylor swift who in
your life right now is someone that you
trust with everything when it comes to
creating new music that
you know they'll be really honest with
you um i mean taylor's still that person
in in my life but like it's like i don't
really
i can't i had a few songs like get
hacked ages ago from like
if i had a video director like one kind
of like
got hacked from there and and leaked so
i'm very careful with like sending songs
on email so i usually do it in person
but since it's been the pandemic the
only person i've really played into is
my wife and she's
i mean she's the one that said bad
habits should be the first single i
remember going in and making all these
like random sounding songs to try and
find a first single
and we were in the car and i was like i
think this one's the first single and
she's like no it's not and i was like i
think this one isn't she's like no it's
not and then bad habits came on which i
wasn't even
considering having on the record and she
was like this is the one so she's
someone who i
trust the opinion of okay yeah she has
really good advice
good opinions trust her always i like
this i like this this combo
um when it comes to the music video
we're definitely seeing
some fangs got some vampire got some
glitter makeup are you trying to tell us
you're a huge fan of twilight
i was always more buffy than twilight
i'm not saying twilight is not without
its
its vampire charm but i think for me for
me it was
like i grew up with buffy and i think i
think buffy was like the original
craze for teen vampire stuff i think
that's where it sort of kick
kicked off if you actually if you get
the buffy dvd it says uh the original uh
the original vampire saga oh i love that
okay so how did you come up with this
idea then for this music video to fit
with bad habits
well i think it was quite kind of
self-explanatory because i think with
bad habits they always come out when the
sun goes down you know you'd never
you never would have like well i mean i
think
some people drink in the day it's not
really my bag but if you it's usually
when the sun goes down is when you have
your first beer and then
it carries on from there and that's when
the bad habits come out and i sort of
think that the
when the sun goes down that's the when
vampires come out or whatever
yeah it's so true um you know one of the
lyrics in
in bad habits is i have nothing left to
lose
when was the last time you felt that way
because at this point
you know your superstar you got a lot
you know riding on your shoulders
when's the last time you felt like you
had nothing left to lose i don't know
that's a very interesting question i
find that
like it's less to do with um
with that with the bad habits it's less
to do with like physical things or like
finance or whatever and more just about
like self-respect
you know i find myself i found myself in
situations where i just like
would make an absolute fool out of
myself and literally have not
nothing else to kind of lose or gain
from the situation and just have to
i think with the bad with the bad habits
is about just digging into the night and
it getting like worse and worse and
worse
yeah nope that absolutely makes sense um
how would you describe how you're
feeling right now
you know obviously it's been a
challenging year for people um
you know but you have such an amazing
support system new music's coming like
how are you feeling right now
i feel extremely nervous like more
nervous than i ever have done about i
feel like
it sounds so weird but i feel like i'm a
new artist again like i'm trying to
re-break
a career like because it's been so long
so i'm uh
i'm nervous but i'm also excited the
reaction that people have
had for the song has been like
overwhelmingly positive
but also like uh surprised
so i think whatever happens the song is
going to come out
and people are going to talk about the
album coming which is kind of my
intention
okay well that's awesome that's very
exciting and that that you know i think
at this point your career too it's kind
of nice to be nervous i mean it's a lot
of emotions but it keeps things very
fresh right
yeah i feel like it i i
feel like if you're not nervous you take
it for granted and i've had
periods of my career where i have taken
it for granted and i feel like
having so much time off now i will never
take it for granted again
like actually hearing i just heard at
one of my tunes on the radio coming here
and it kind of filled me with such like
joy whereas before you i don't know it
just
you kind of do it for so long you get
jaded and to take that sort of stuff for
granted but i've
i've been so long out of the limelight
that even like dipping a toe in has got
me excited
about releasing music that's awesome was
there ever a point when you were
i'm gonna release the bad habits and
you're working on it that you ever
wanted to collaborate with somebody on
this song or was this always going to be
yours
so i did a whole kind of side project
which was my collaborations project
where i basically worked with all the
people i wanted to work with over the
years but
i don't like doing collaborations on my
albums so
uh you know i would do my solo albums
and then i did this collaborations
side project and that was uh all i've
ever
really wanted to do in terms of
collaborating but now i'm kind of back
to my own stuff i'm
i'm i'm good i've kind of scratched that
itch
yeah um with this song obviously going
to be on people's
summer playlists who's on your summer
playlist right now who are you loving as
an artist or even just a song
uh do you know the streets
i don't okay so they're a really really
big british group from i mean they've
probably been about 15 years but they
wrote a song about england opening up
called 21st of june who's got the bag
and that is
that i mean that's all me and my friends
listen to i mean sadly 21st of june is
not the day that
england opened up anymore but it's that
for me is the song of the summer
um i'm not sure it necessarily fits on
canadian radio
but it definitely fits on well does it
fit on each
other it just basically goes 21st of
june
who's got the bag and it's uh it's good
i like that i love that so much um well
thank you so much i really appreciate
your time
loving this song can't wait to get
everyone's reaction from it i mean it's
going to be a smash it obviously thank
you so much
you